foreign
[Music]
new data just in I want to see how you
guys feel about this a new study shows
that people who smoke weed are more
likely to get lung disease than people
who smoke cigarettes interesting maybe
because there's no filter
paid for by Philip Morris I wouldn't be
surprised if both of those were a lot of
money I bet it's true people get jacked
up from smoking pot yeah the resin
probably sticks harder than the tobacco
with all the Vapes and stuff I bet it's
like you know a little sketchy sketchy
Frontier so they did this in a
controlled study among Like A specific
group they got people that smoke only
weed people that smoke only cigarettes
and the people that don't smoke of the
weed smokers 75 percent of them develop
emphysema of the cigarette smokers 67
percent of them it's still both [__]
high it's still high like they're acting
like that [__] for the non-smokers five
percent well they say like health-wise
you shouldn't smoke anything like at all
they say that or does Nick done Health
yeah professional safe and what if
instead of this way I did it like this
way
that's just cool my nose hairs and it's
got to be like this though too you can't
get emphysema that way
the Celia on your nose hairs will trap
the resin before it goes to your lung it
definitely has The Vibes of a Philip
Morris paid uh study dude all the
anti-vaping [__] makes me laugh like
like how it's destroying lives we've
talked about this too but it always
cracks me up the no vaping team no
vaping yeah no Vivint team
but don't like uh a lot of cigarette
brands have interest in Jewel and things
like that yeah for sure for sure because
I know they bought into um I forgot a
big big tobacco did buy a a huge portion
of Jewel how come you never got into the
joys of drugs
you just never wanted to do it yeah I
just wasn't into it I bet it's purely
interest-based for you I bet you just
had no interest in it and you're just
like yeah I don't give a [__] yeah I
don't know I think it's because like
growing up I was I was usually the peer
pressure like I like I like why don't
you do drugs but I never did it yeah I
like to pressure people to do funny [__]
and so I wasn't gonna go get that guy a
[__] yeah
yeah that's usually so I think like I
was never on the receiving end and it
just so happens I I was never in a
position where like eight dudes were
doing drugs and I was the odd one out
like usually
people left me alone you never just like
out of curiosity I don't know what peer
pressured me to do it I was begging to
[__] find it
when I heard about it I was like what is
this thing I think I was afraid I think
it was honestly as a kid I was afraid of
it because I saw the the little like
PSAs and all the like they work of kids
like losing their [__] or dads beating
their kids and like it worked on me for
real I was like damn like I don't wanna
I'm scared I was just scared of it like
the idea I didn't do any drugs until uh
college so like same thing I was also
scared but then once you get into
college and you start being around like
people like that that are doing it using
it you know what I mean having some good
stories everybody's laughing it's very
social so you didn't get any of that
type of peer pressure either because I
was around you and when when you guys
were all still in college and the party
I understood that like everyone was
having a good time I think it's because
I was never a downer I think I would
notice people get pressured when they're
not as fun if that makes sense I would I
would observe that and be like oh this
guy's just kind of not with the energy
of the room and so they're like dude why
are you [__] loosen up take a drink
do something you know but like I was
usually there but before people were
high I was already kind of like crazy
you think I showed up early yeah
that you were already on something dude
lots of people have always assumed they
probably never offered you anything
because they're just like fun loving
individual yeah but I I never got faced
with that I think the most I've ever
been pressured was from girls that was
the most I've ever been pressured come
on virginity well because I think it's
like a take my version that's it that's
a problem yeah it's like a thing where
um here's one very common stupid thing I
would hear all the time uh when a girl
would be like I'd be hanging with her at
a bar or at like a drinking uh scenario
and she'll say
let's let's have a drink let's you know
whatever I'm like oh I actually don't
drink and then it'll get into this whole
thing of like why just today judging me
ha you're judging me right now huh and
then like eventually if I feel prone to
[__] explain it then I would have to
be like I've actually never had a drink
before so I don't think it's you're not
gonna be able to talk me into it tonight
you know yeah and then they'll do this
dumb thing where it's like well I could
be your first drink
take your first drink with me it'll be
like a monument I'm like yeah really I
waited [__] 25 years to take it with
you yeah
the longer you don't do something the
less you're tempted by it you know like
the longer you haven't had it I think I
got through the four years where I could
have been talked into it I got through
those couriers and then after that it's
just something that you don't do I used
to do that with watching the Titanic
movie I'm not kidding because everyone
[__] wants to take him abstaining
from it when I came here I was like I'm
not watching this [__] movie
everyone's talking about this movie not
watch this phone did anyone tell you
there was titties
all right If Only They have
three hours to just see a titties okay
but at that age I'm not the biggest like
Winslet guy so I wasn't like needing to
see those two days right yeah those are
period piece titties because I was like
oh my God there's titties well I gotta
watch this then in that era if Titanic
was starring Pamela Anderson I would
have been
this guy in line
I hear there
with Pam I'm in I'll watch it I'll be
the first time that is cool but no I
definitely
um and then I'm with my first girlfriend
and she wanted to watch it and like have
there's like a double date me and my
buddy and his girlfriend and then me and
my girlfriend and then she wanted to
watch Titanic I was like [__] it and I
cried as a beautiful movie I wish I
thought sooner I actually really did
like it yeah hey Titanic is a [__]
good movie good [__] movie but I went
into it you know because you're at that
age and you're just like you're like I'm
too cool for the [__] yeah and then like
by the end of it I'm like oh my God this
is so sad like like especially when the
water's filling up the room and [__] I
was like God damn this it is actually
pretty you know who put me on a chick
flicks Bart
how and when because we were talking
about like favorite movie of all time
and all this [__] right he goes oh man
notebook like notebooks [__] sick
Rick is an interesting word to use but
your book is hella sick is sick right
and I'm all like I'm like wait what
cause dank dude you know like as you're
growing up you don't gravitate toward
those movies like that's not the first
thing a boy goes and checks right yeah
so then when you so then when you get
when you get to that age you just you
lose out on a whole era of like good
movies that's true because your mind is
like oh that's all girl stuff yeah it's
on you you yeah I feel like every single
time I was watching some of that stuff
it was like
I had such a strong Joy of watching that
with the chick that I was maybe kind of
into or something oh yeah that's true
you don't want to seem like a [__]
though no like I was ashamed that I was
crying
oh in terms of crying well you actually
cried I cried well I'm not kidding I
cried watching tight [__] I know in the
movie theater like a [__] no I was at
my girlfriend's house with I'm crowd
watching The Notebook the first time
notebook was good bro once she [__]
like once once you like forget or once
she forgets or something right where
they're like slow dancing yeah I'm
talking about wakanda forever
dude that's a good one you ever uh hear
what Neil deGrasse Tyson said about
Titanic what do you say um he has a
gripe with it because uh there's of
course where uh Rose is looking at the
sky he can shut the [__] up she's
looking at the sky you know when when
they're like after it's sunk and she's
looking up he said that's the incorrect
Sky gosh this guy I can't [__] take
it anymore that's why nerds get [__]
up yeah dude but he didn't get [__] up
enough dude that's true he said like
it's clearly a copy paste of one side to
the other and that's not what the Stars
would be at that point oh yeah oh [__] I
told James Cameron by the way he told
James Cameron like way back he bets
Cameron told him to go [__] himself one
of James Cameron's Prides is that it
went into such meticulous detail
everything's correct correct correct and
he's like hey what happened with that
Sky though and then um and then James
Cameron at first said oh I wasn't there
during post so that might have slipped
by and and then a few years later Neil
deGrasse Tyson ran into again and asked
him again like hey what's up with that
sky like uh what happened it's really
pissing me off still yeah and then um
and then James Cameron said
you know you know what's funny to this
day Titanic's grossed over a billion
dollars I wonder how much more that
would have been if the sky was different
that's the best city I love it that's
the best thing I can love it that's the
response that's sick as hell twice if
you're Neil deGrasse Tyson bro let's
bring it up once and that's it yeah
James Cameron gets to do and say
anything he wants after making Titanic
except for maybe five Avatar sequels
maybe I mean well he already he already
made two and three and he said if people
don't watch two and three he's not gonna
do four and five bro I didn't even see
one you didn't see it is it I think I
missed the boat good job there's a two
yeah two comes out in December oh it's
the best it was good it was really great
it was surreal in the theater watch it
watch number two this December in IMAX
after you watch number one but watch it
it's meant for big screen yeah I watched
it on IMAX do we need the glasses are
they doing the glasses still I'd be down
I'd be down yeah
Avatar is a visually beautiful movie
with a very whatever boring same it's
Pocahontas it's stunning but it's like
yeah it's a retelling done right I think
yeah
I mean it's incredible the other day
they're like it ain't no Reservoir Dogs
but it's good this this meme the other
day was like they showed a picture of
the Avatar right they're like this dude
[__] he he turned his back on his
whole race the human race just for some
alien poon man one way to look at it he
transitioned
he went inner species and [__]